[Música]
en una carrera contrarreloj el senado
estadounidense aprobó el acuerdo para
suspender el techo de la deuda hasta
2025 la misma Ya había recibido el visto
bueno de la cámara baja el proyecto de
ley llega tras varias semanas de
disputas partidistas entre demócratas y
republicanos que han llevado al país a
coquetear con la posibilidad del primer
impago de su historia en un tuit del
presidente joaida lo calificó de Gran
Victoria para la economía y para los
estadounidenses comentarios de los que
se hizo eco el líder de la mayoría
demócrata en el senado
los demócratas se sienten muy bien esta
noche hemos salvado al país del azote
del impago a pesar de que había algunos
en el otro bando que querían el impago
que querían llevarnos al impago puede
que estemos un poco cansados pero lo
hemos conseguido Así que estamos muy muy
contentos
una victoria pero no sin concesiones la
demanda inicial de los republicanos de
con el gasto no relacionado con la
defensa durante 10 años se redujo a dos
años pero lograron reasignar los 30 mil
millones de dólares del fondo de ayuda a
Los afectados por la crisis que quedaban
sin gastar los demócratas consiguieron
los 80 mil millones de dólares
necesarios para reforzar la agencia
tributaria con el fin de aplicar
impuestos a los estadounidenses más
ricos y se agilizará la concesión de
licencias para nuevos proyectos
energéticos donde de combustibles
fósiles como de energías renovables la
oficina presupuestaria independiente del
Congreso afirma que la legislación
supondrá un ahorro de uno punto cinco
billones de dólares en la próxima década
aunque los republicanos más
conservadores y los demócratas más
liberales están descontentos con el
proyecto hubo suficientes congresistas
centristas como para que la cuerda
llegará a buen Puerto ahora se dirige a
la casa blanca donde vayan ha dicho que
lo firmará lo antes posible